bonsoir bienvenue ça vous regarde en
direct ravi de vous retrouver au
sommaire ce soir le monde selon marine
le pen ou emmanuel macron l'otan la
russie l'europe les deux finalistes de
la présidentielle défendent une vision
de la diplomatie diamétralement opposées
sur ce plateau ce soir face à face entre
deux de leurs soutiens respectifs sur la
politique étrangère la députée
européenne en marche nathalie d'oiseaux
faso porte parole du rassemblement
national julien odoul dans un instant
avec notre grand témoin ce soir nous
essaierons de répondre à cette question
marine le pen est-elle d'extrême droite
la candidate récuse cette étiquette
depuis des années elle a méthodiquement
retravaillé son positionnement et
surtout son image mais si tout ceci
n'était qu'un masque c'est la tête de
rappel lorca communicants et expert
associé à la fondation jean jaurès avec
nous ce soir enfin dans le calme ce soir
les retrouvailles des manuels macro et
d'heures edouard philippe dans sa ville
du havre
on verra cela avec brandon ouaret
isabelle lasserre revient sur ce mot de
génocide
employé par joe biden mais pas par le
chef de l'état français pour qualifier
les crimes russe en ukraine et puis
l'oeil de blacko qui ausculte ce soir la
lente agonie du ps voilà pour le menu
c'est parti
[Musique]
et bienvenue à vous chers
téléspectateurs dis-moi comment tu vois
le monde je te dirai qui tu es rarement
une campagne présidentielle n'aura fait
autant de place aux questions
internationales la guerre en ukraine
oblige les deux finalistes à la clarté
projet contre projet bonsoir nathalie
l'oiseau soi et merci d'avoir accepté ce
face-à-face députée européenne du groupe
renaissance renew dans lequel siègent
les élus ma cronista bruxelles ancien
ministre chargé des affaires européennes
face à vous ce soir julien odoul bonsoir
joie bienvenue porte parole du
rassemblement national et puis bon soir
richard on soir myriam richard vers
l'est vont m'accompagner ce soir pour
questionner nos deux invités avec un
regard européen puisque vous suivez les
questions européennes pour le quotidien
suisse le temps dont vous êtes le
correspondant parisien on va commencer
par le programme de marine le pen
qu'elle a présenté hier russie otan
europe allemagne à quoi ressemblerait le
nouvel ordre mondial si elle était élue
le 24 avril prochain on voit cela avec
les os
au moment où la russie s'apprête à
lancer une nouvelle offensive militaire
en ukraine la déclaration a de quoi
surprendre marine le pen prône le
rapprochement entre l'otan et moscou
tech la guerre russo ukrainienne sera
achevé et aura été réglé par un traité
de paix je me prononcerai en faveur de
la mise en oeuvre d'un rapprochement
stratégique entre l'otan et la russie
comme cela avait été naguère envisagée
c'est l'intérêt de la france et de
l'europe mais aussi je crois des états
unis alors que joe biden parle de
génocide en ukraine emmanuel macron
comme marine le pen de crimes de guerre
la candidate rassemblement national
tente ce matin de justifier sa ligne
c'est une vision à long terme que j'ai
exprimée hier quand on parle de
politique internationale on essaye
d'avoir une vision à long terme et
évidemment je n'ai pas fait l'impasse
sur la nécessité dans l'avenir bien
entendu de
d'essayer de faire en sorte que l'otan
reprennent des contacts avec la russie
pour la grèce qui est en train de s'en
excuser moi après après lorsqu'un traité
paix aura été signés enfin vous voyez
j'ai quand même pris énormément bien
entendu de précaution une ambition qui
détonne d'autant que la candidate
souhaite quitter le commandement intégré
de l'organisation
autre sujet l'union européenne il est
clair que cela n'est ni un projet ni un
besoin pour la candidate mais plutôt une
contrainte le fric site n'est nullement
notre projet nous nous voulons réformer
l'union européenne de l'intérieur mais
plus de nous libérerons du carcan
bruxellois tout en restant dans l'union
européenne plus nous nous tournerons
vers le vaste dans son programme marine
le pen plaide pour une europe à la carte
prendre ce qu'ils arrangent et laisser
ce qui la dérange elle souhaite pour
cela la création d'une alliance
européenne des nations qui a vocation à
se substituer progressivement à l'union
européenne avec cette contradiction à
gérer comment se débarrasser de l'union
européenne sans parler de fric site
quant au couple franco allemand marine
le pen prône le divorce fin des
coopérations avec berlin et arts et du
soutien français à la revendication
allemande d'un siège permanent au
conseil de sécurité de l'onu et
l'allemagne s'affirme ainsi comme le
négatif absolue de l'identité
stratégiques françaises une ligne
inamicale avec l'allemagne qui dénote à
côté d'une hostilité bien mesurer à
l'égard de la russie
alors on va reprendre point par point on
va commencer par ce qu'est le plus
surpris faut bien le dire cette question
du rapprochement stratégique entre
l'otan et la russie julien odoul après
la guerre
la candidate comment au fond elle peut
assumer aujourd'hui un changement
d'alliance dans ce contexte de guerre
après ma salle debout de ça après les
viols de femmes après les exactions
après le feu sur marioupol comment c'est
possible de dire voilà ce qu'il faut
faire alors qu'on ne connaît même pas
l'issue de ce conflit on ne sait même
pas si bladimir poutine va tomber s'il
sera encore président pour les dix
prochaines années déjà marine le pen a
rappelé son soutien au peuple ukrainien
elle l'a rappelé dès le premier jour et
surtout la nécessité de garantir la
souveraineté d'ukraine la sécurité
d'ukraine la pérennité l'ukraine ça
c'est fondamental
marine le pen est attaché à la
souveraineté nationale pour la france
mais aussi pour toutes les nations du
monde dont l'ukraine évidemment marine
le pen a exprimé aussi sa vision à moyen
long terme puisque évidemment que
l'objectif c'est de sortir de ce conflit
la russie ne sera pas une ennemie
advitam eternam
l'allemagne n'a pas eu d une ennemie
advitam eternam nous avons eu trois
conflits majeurs nous avons eu des
occupations nous avait eu des drames
avec les ânes à réconcilier
exactement mais la réconciliation avec
la russie prendra du temps pour autant
pour notre pays il faut quand même bien
mesurer que et pour l'europe d'ailleurs
que de jeter la russie dans les bras de
la chine terre de jeter à la fois le
pays le plus peuplé du monde avec le
pays le plus grand du monde le pays qui
est lusine du monde avec le pays qui
contient le plus de matière première ce
serait un désastre pour la france et
l'europe ça ferait une méga puissance
dans les intérêts seraient hostiles aux
intérêts européens nous ne voulons pas
ça donc l'objectif c'est pas d'être
naïfs nous ne voulons pas encore une
fois m signé un blanc-seing va pouvoir
vous envisagez se rapproche d'une
alliance militaire qui me retient n'est
pas éternelle la russie est éternel la
russie sera toujours là le peuple russe
sera toujours là donc nous nous
souhaitons que à terme mais après la
guerre quoi après poutine est âpre mais
après la guerre après la guerre vous
savez on a des relations avec des états
qui ont commis des massacres et qui ont
commis des guerres totalement illégitime
par exemple l'arabie saoudite l'arabie
saoudite depuis 2015 a déclenché un
conflit ignoble et à massacrer des
petits enfants au yémen pour autant que
ce soit la grande bretagne que ce soit
la france entretiennent toujours des
relations avec l'arabie saoudite donc il
faut qu'une vision de long terme il faut
et vite être impitoyable avec la russie
notamment sur les sanctions sur la
condamnation aider l'ukraine à aider les
réfugiés ukrainien pour autant voir sur
le long terme comment on sort de
l'impasse et comment on rétablit des
relations pacifiées avec une grande
puissance notamment nucléaires contre
l'île aux oiseaux ce rapprochement
stratégique à terme et si même
envisageable alors d'abord je voudrais
reprendre un petit peu ce que j'ai
entendu parce que c'est difficile d'être
porte-parole de marine le pen quand
marine le pen a en réalité toujours été
hostile à la souveraineté de l'ukraine
elle a proclamé que la crimée et et
russe
les députés européens du rassemblement
national sont allés d'ailleurs à maintes
reprise en crimée annexée elle a
critiqué la livraison d'armes à
l'ukraine ce n'est pas une manière
d'aider l'ukraine ces députés était
hostile à ce qu'on en voit une aide
financière à l'ukraine juste avant la
guerre des lieux zeo vata bruxelles
d'ailleurs elle est interdite de séjour
en ukraine donc les ukrainiens ne s'y
trompe pas alors je veux bien qu'on
essaye de ripoliner la façade d'un parti
qui depuis de très nombreuses années
depuis jean marie le pen et marine le
pen a pris sa suite a fait un choix qui
est d'être en admiration et je reprend
les termes de marine le pen pour
vladimir poutine
le rassemblement national à parler de la
russie comme d'un modèle de démocratie
on ya j'ai entendu marine le pen dire
que la liberté d'expression en russie
était plus forte qu'en france c'était
après l'assassinât d'avancé l'adonis
qualifient d'ores et déjà
glissant je vous ai laissé passer je
vous demande de me laisser parler je
reviens de boudhha
je voulais me faire une opinion moi même
de ce qui s'était passé entendre les
survivants des atrocités qui ont été
commanditées par les commandants de
l'armée russe je reviens duce j'entends
marine le pen dire allez une alliance
avec la russie bon quand ça sera terminé
vous savez ce à quoi ça m'a fait penser
munich
1938 et je n'ai pas envie que la france
soit dirigée par une mycose
ou alors madame l'oiseau puisque vous
êtes dans l'art la fiq news en
permanence vous savez qu'en ce moment
qu'ils appellent bladinières poutine
tous les jours c'est monsieur macron
qui monsieur macron qui a reçu d'abord
une boutade oui régulièrement qui
entretient des relations régulières
entre états
monsieur poussins dames le ps et pour
démarrer les finales et son mari c'est
raconter n'importe quoi madame louise
habitude
une banque pourquoi
je ne suis pas n'importe quoi est ce que
madame le pen est endetté aux abois
zougoise on est très tôt madame le pen
matin des matins blêmes
déterminer s'il vous plaît madame
l'oiseau être en opposition à ce que
vous dites c'est pas être insultant
voilà c'est juste être plus il de jeudi
des faits
musulmane a su bête étant dépendant de
main qui va prendre soin parfois la
crimée il ya eu un référendum peut-être
que vous contestez le droit des peuples
à disposer d'eux mêmes c'est votre droit
le respect pour le
respectons respectons évidemment
respecte les frontières aux pactes les
frontières historiques et on respecte
les référendum ensuite en ce qui
concerne la dir poutine marine le pen a
toujours été très claire elle a dénoncé
à la dénoncer depuis le début cette
invasion ignoble elle a condamné
l'action de 22h poutine ça n'a jamais
encore une fois fait débat et elle est
d'ailleurs et d'ailleurs elle a salué
une équation vous répondiez l'âme et
l'esprit munichois c'est très amusant en
fait
c'est pas de fêtards regard désolé il ya
des choix qu'elles font parler la venue
non non ça ne fait pas rire vous savez
ça fait pas rire du tout même quand
monsieur macron fédé selphy avec
monsieur monsieur le prince héritier
d'arabie saoudite
quoi ça vous intéresse pas parce que
peut-être que ce sont des petits enfants
arabes qui sont morts il sera si jamais
je sais d'où l'effet du gaz et
l'invasion il s'est troué monsieur
monsieur madame
chaleureux avec ce criminel voilà
surtout là c'est la police il a été
mon cas mais ça va reprendre le fil mais
need et comment a été démarrée par des
rebelles houthi qui ont pris le pouvoir
par la force soutenu par les amis
iraniens de madame le pen donc vous
allez des indignations sélectives
c'est très amusant en fait non ce n'est
pas la russie quand ce n'est pas la
russie en fait tout est tolérable alors
oui j'aime les films sont acceptés quand
ça concerne l'arabie saoudite ont fermé
les yeux
sur et intolérant l'eau du savon doux le
pardon revenons sur un autre aspect de
ce qui a été dit c'est à dire l'otan
donc madame le pen d'abord elle
préconise un rapprochement à l'otan moi
j'aimerais savoir qu'est ce qui lui fait
penser première question qu'elle sera
entendue et qu'elle aura les moyens
d'être entendue au sein d'une alliance
dont elle propose par ailleurs de
quitter le commandement intégré hélas ma
question sera simple qu'est-ce que ça
rapportera à la france si elle est élue
de quitter le commandement intégré en
quoi à votre avis la france regagnera de
la marge de manoeuvre en quittant le
commandement intégré d'une alliance qui
pour l'instant semble t'il joue assez
bien son rôle de protecteur des
démocraties occidentales oui l'otan j'ai
dit assez bien relativisé l'absurde le
temps il faut pas être naïf aussi avec
l'otan fait je ne sais pas parce que
aujourd'hui une invasion russe ce qui
est naïf je pars les incapacités parce
que l'otan est aussi vous reconnaissez
que l'audience et
les nations européennes se sont
réveillés une solidarité européenne
notamment la pologne qui étaient vos
gémonies par les européistes comme
damien loiseau la polonia a joué son
rôle la hongrie a joué son rôle tant
pour l'accueil des enfants en parler
mais la question était sur l'os
avant la guerre en ukraine il y avait
une tentative de rapprochement ou 8
entre l'otan et la russie aux américains
brussels open ne souhaite pas au trot
bureau à bruxelles ok au qg de l'otan
figurez vous que le bureau de la russie
le bureau de représentation de la russie
était mitoyenne bureau de la suisse donc
je peux vous dire que je connaissais
bien ces deux bureaux sauf que c'était
il y a longtemps maintenant qu'est-ce
qui vous fait penser que madame le pen
arrivant au conseil de l'otan va obtenir
gain de cause quand elle propose un
futur rapprochement avec la russie
j'aimerais savoir moi j'aimerais sur le
comment c'est le comment qui m'intéresse
l'objectif le comment se fera sur le
long terme évidemment c'est parce à la
question c'est comment mais comme
commencé du vent alors madame l'eau en
matière de vent je pense que vous êtes
spécialiste je pense que vous avez une
un parc éolien chez vous mais
sincèrement
vraiment besoin d'être je suis pas je
suis pas trop je suis pas je suis pas
agressif je vous réponds
je suis non plus en fait j'y arriverai
pas
je rappelle juste que la règle de l'otan
vous la connaissez évidemment c'est
celle de l'unanimité des 30 pays membres
de la coalition comment madame le pen
obtient ce rapprochement en imaginant
que le conflit il faut le souhaiter se
termine marine le pen sera présidente de
la république française c'est à dire
membres du conseil de sécurité des
nations unies c'est pas une petite
puissance et une puissance qui pèse et
marine le pen fera en sorte avec nos
partenaires de d'oeuvrer pour un rapport
pacifié avec la russie à terme parce que
c'est les intérêts aussi de la paix en
europe de la stabilité de la
souveraineté ukrainien je pense que la
crise aujourd'hui on peut en tirer les
leçons évidemment qu'aujourd'hui les
coupables et responsables sont les
russes il n'y a pas de débat mais il
faut peut-être revoir tout ce qui n'a
pas été fait avant tout ce qui peut être
l'avancé de l'otan qui était mal gérée
peut-être que les ruches aussi il ya eu
des susceptibilités tous leurs
éléments intégrés se retirer du
commandement intégré l'otan c'est quand
même un signe de défiance dont qu'elle
veut dans le même temps obtenir une
inflexion de l'alliance et la quitter en
partie est ce que ce n'est pas
contradictoire non regardez c'était la
position de la france entre 1966 et 2009
et que je sache il n'y avait pas de
guerre en ukraine même il y eut d'autres
guerres il me semble que d'autres
guerres il ya eu d'autres il ya eu
d'autres guerres il ya eu une guerre il
faut bien le rappeler en ex-yougoslavie
n'y plusieurs guerres d'ailleurs en ex
yougoslavie au kosovo ça n'a pas empêché
la france d'être active ça n'a pas
empêché la france de jouer son rôle à la
fois de puissance d' équilibre ces deux
puissances et quid il faut qu'on avance
vous dire a ajouté un petit mot là
dessus aussi j'aimerais qu'on parle de
l'europe je voulais dire tout simplement
qu'aujourd'hui vladimir poutine a montré
assez clairement ce qu'ils pensaient
d'autant il n'a pas du tout l'intention
de s'en rapprocher et les membres de
l'otan n'ont aucune intention de se
rapprocher de quelqu'un qui les menacent
parce que non seulement ils agressent
l'ukraine mais il me lasse la finlande
l'estonie il a fait la liste de tous
ceux dont il n'acceptait pas le libre
arbitre vous vous dites est ce que ce
n'est pas la faute de l'otan vous
reprenez mot pour mot le narratif
baptême là on avance on
avoue m à l'heure de toute façon c'est
très clair vous l'avez dit assumer le
encore une fois je re buts
n'étaient pas dans l'otan depuis 2008
hawkins a n'avait pas avancé d'un
millimètre pour l'ukraine dans l'otan ce
que je regrette pour elle parce qu'elle
ne serait pas en train de vivre un
martyr comme elle le fait aujourd'hui
heureusement aujourd'hui la france
membre du commandement intégré de l'otan
nous sommes la troisième armée de l'otan
vous voudriez nous mettre sur l'étagère
nous voulons être là au coeur des
décisions très claires vous aide à ceux
me roy d'accord sur ce que j'ai la rue
on avance sur l'europe parce qu'on
essaye de comprendre marine le pen dit
très clairement que la france si elle
est élue reste au sein de 27 dans
l'union européenne pas de frais exit
sauf que et vous allez nous dire
nathalie l'oiseau vous avez été ministre
en charge des relations si c'est tenable
elle considère qui va y avoir une forme
d'europe des nations qui va se
substituer je regarde votre programme
c'est écrit noir sur blanc dans votre
programme une nouvelle alliance
européenne des nations qui va se
substituer à l'union européenne elle
remet en cause la participation
française au budget de l'union elle
diminue
importante la participation française
elle réaffirme la supériorité du droit
français sur le droit européen est ce
que crouch mans et là je parle sous
votre contrôle vous dire defacto ses
pains frais xix deçà c'est contraire à
tous les traités non c'est pas un freak
site alors il faut rétablir certaines
choses marine le pen ne souhaite pas
sortir de l'union européenne marine le
pen ne souhaite pas rétablir la peine de
mort marine le pen ne souhaite pas
supprimer le mariage homosexuel s'est
dit parce que ce sont les faits que new
skies sont balancés par la macro ni
depuis quelques jours voilà nous nous ce
que nous souhaitons c'est une évolution
effectivement l'union européenne nous
sommes européens et nous sommes sur le
continent européennes participant la
même civilisation
nous en sommes fiers il ya aucun
problème là dessus pour autant la
structure technocratique parce que la
question c'est pas l'appartenance à
l'europe et pas te sentir européen c'est
la structure technocratique de l'union
européenne aujourd'hui fait du mal au
peuple français comme à d'autres peuples
européens et nous nous souhaitons
qu'elle évolue et nous souhaitons
récupérer des souverainetés
vous l'a souhaitée et voulue qu'elle a
enfreint les règles communes donc là
vous allez avoir un problème si elle
était règles de technocratie alors c'est
un vrai guide qui ne dit pas son nom ou
pas alors c'est évidemment un frais exit
masqué c'est à dire qu'on change
l'emballage pour être un peu plus
présentable ce n'est pas la girouette
qui change c'est le vent maintenant que
marine le pen a compris qu'elle avait
fait peur aux français en 2017 elle
essaye de dire autre chose mais ça ne
tient pas la route et je suis assez
consterné de voir une candidate à la
présidence de la république qui prend
les français pour des imbéciles
et qu'est ce qui peut se passer ici avec
ce programme n'avait pas vraiment sur le
dr france l on ne pénètre pas votre
cotisation et en ne respectant pas les
règles
quel est le club on est dans un club
l'on n'est pas au fouquet's l'oiseau
excusez moi
mais ligne l'union européenne compte
tenu de ce que nous versons alors compte
tenu de ce que nous retrouvons là nous
sommes perdants le peuple français est
perdant les emplois français sont
perdants dont il est jusqu'à aujourd'hui
c'est ça
votre idéologie mi-temps
qu'on est plus forts l'union européenne
depuis quand est-ce que c'est faux est
ce que je viens de faire avec le colis
de monsieur odoul c'est grâce à l'union
européenne les vaccins on connaît on
connaît alors je vous remercie c'est un
jeu ce que j'allais dire il rappelle
qu'on est la seule essence et en plus
conseil de sécurité décide unis qui n'a
pas eu de vaccins nationale et c'est lié
notamment à la politique de ses missions
et de vassalisation de monsieur macron
pas une seconde monsieur monsieur aulas
explique de respect pour les gens sans
l'union européenne pour lui vendre
n'aurions pas eu des vaccins disponibles
pour tous les européens nous n'aurions
pas été le continent le mieux vacciner
du monde et gratuitement pour chacun de
nos concitoyens sans l'union européenne
n'ayant pas eu le plan de relance a
qu'une fruits
à rennes
c'est dur expression de la france qui
peut être ouverte si marine le pen était
avec soit une réalité dans des pays
comme la pologne par exemple ont décidé
seraient repris mais le relais on est le
deuxième pays d'europe où sera jamais
isolé vous le savez les gens qui feront
les d'allier puissance qu'on l'ait
l'allié de mal à
lyon la hongrie de viktor
la hong peut-être demain la république
tchèque la slovaquie mais par excusez
moi non écoutez vous êtes dans un monde
parallèle à nos frontières d'israël
mondial la france est présente sur tous
les continents
la france est le deuxième pays d'un
point de vue démographique de l'union
européenne est la deuxième économie
européenne vous pensé un seul instant
que l'union européenne va tenir et va se
faire sans la france c'est pas juste
faire les amateurs sont très inquiets
et bien justement
voilà l'occasion à ce que moi j'ai
j'avoue que j'ai un étonnement parce que
vous l'avez dit il se trouve que je
représente un média suisse la suisse est
hors de l'union européenne et que l'on
sache c'est un pays qui se portent
plutôt bien même si elle est peut-être
grosse et molle comme dirait madame
l'oiseau jeu la tactique jeu la tactique
moi je suis très ému au doigt pourquoi
madame le pen qui par ailleurs veut de
la démocratie directe et veut un
référendum pourquoi elle ne propose pas
aux français un référendum sur la sortie
de l'union européenne j'avoue que je
suis étonné par ce que je peux vous dire
qu'en suisse nous avons eu ce référendum
il avait eu lieu en 1992 il ne portait
pas sur l'union européenne mais sur
l'espace économique européen les suisses
ont dit non le gouvernement a respecté
la parole du peuple pourquoi vous n'osez
pas avoir ce référendum et mais marine
le pen n'a pas peur des ja du du vote du
cas pourquoi ne le propose pas et veut
justement marine le pen considère que
l'objectif de retrouver nos
souverainetés la sécurité la prospérité
du peuple français aujourd'hui est
compatible avec le maintien dans l'union
européenne elle va tout faire ça c'est
elle qui
le dit et notamment et notamment si un
moment donné il ya un blocage et
d'ailleurs elle l'a dit s'il ya un
blocage elle posera la question peuple
français en disant je ne peux pas tout
faire ce que je vous avais promis
notamment pour le retour des
souverainetés notamment pour des marges
de manoeuvre des libertés donc elle
posera la question que vous ne lui
on est pas si mon ex est alors rien du
tout cas c'est pas ce président de
décaler un peu on peut marine le pen
peut et elle l'a dit récupérer un
maximum de souveraineté et faire en
sorte d'évoluer l'union européenne est
ce que vous savez la france est un
modèle la france et
non pas un repoussoir comme avec
monsieur mal et on va avancer on va à
présent s'intéresser à ce que propose
emmanuel macron qui je le rappelle
préside le conseil de l'union européenne
à maître mot c'est la souveraineté
européenne je suis pas sûr que ce
concept si à votre oreille avec un
couple franco-allemand renforcer là où
marine le pen au contraire veut tout
simplement leur ombre regardez ce sujet
signé tibhrine ac le 24 avril nous
pouvons faire le choix de la france et
de l'europe assemble la france et
l'europe ensemble indissociable
dès le soir du premier tour dans le duel
qui s'annonce avec marine le pen
emmanuel macron trace un clivage très
nette martelé mardi encore à strasbourg
le projet européen qui est le nôtre
aujourd'hui nous devons le défendre ne
laissez pas s'installer des projets qui
sans le dire ou en le disant propose de
sortir de l'europe la foule aux pieds la
fragile dans ce duel le projet européen
d' emmanuel macron est celui d'une
europe renforcée conditions à ses yeux
de la souveraineté de la france une
indépendance qui passe notamment par la
relance de grands projets européens
du nord
[Musique]
le président candidat défend ainsi
l'idée d'une coopération renforcée entre
états membres de nouvelles missions
pourraient aussi être confiées à l'ue
non via de nouveaux traités qui pourrait
donner lieu à référendum pilier de cette
politique le couple franco-allemand
qu'emmanuel mâcon souhaite encore
renforcer pour lui l'allemagne est un
partenaire indispensable
l'europe doit changer faire bouger les
lignes emmanuel macron aimerait aussi le
faire dans d'autres domaines l'énergie
d'abord avec le souhait que les
européens s'unissent pour sortir de la
dépendance énergétique envers la russie
l'écologie ensuite via l'instauration
d'une taxe carbone aux frontières
l'économie enfin avec l'idée d'une
convergence sur les règles sociales et
fiscales notamment autre sujet l'espace
schengen emmanuel macron souhaite le
réformer pour lutter contre
l'immigration clandestine
objectif renforcer les contrôles aux
frontières de l'union mais aussi à
l'intérieur où des contrôles pourraient
être rétablis dans certains cas bien
précis dernier sujet la défense ambition
affichée dès 2017 l'europe devra ainsi
être doté d'une force commune
d'intervention d'un budget de défense
commun et d'une doctrine commune pour
agir un chantier que la guerre en
ukraine a rendu d'autant plus urgent aux
yeux du président
voilà et sur tous ces sujets là encore
des visions diamétralement opposées sur
l'europe de la défense nathalie l'oiseau
sur le renforcement du couple franco
allemand et sur la possibilité d'aller
au fond plus vite et plus fort a
plusieurs mais pas forcément à 27 une
europe à peu à deux vitesses il faut
aller jusque là en tout cas pas l'europe
de celui qui veut aller moins vite et le
but n'est pas d'aller vite pour aller
vite le but n'est pas de tout mettre au
niveau européen mais de traiter au
niveau européen ce qui nous permet de
faire face à la chine vous avez raison
tout à l'heure julien odoul la grande la
super puissance chinoise on ne la laisse
pas face à nous les mains dans les
poches mais la vraie alliance dont nous
avons besoin c'est l'alliance au niveau
européen pour imposer nos choix nos
choix de consommateurs nos choix de
protecteur de l'environnement et c'est
évidemment à 27 qu'on peut le faire mais
quitte aussi à avancer sur des projets
industriels te sembler comme on le fait
lui ville tout le monde même l'avion en
commun comme on l'a la défense
européenne avec l'allemagne schengen
tout le monde n'est pas dans schengen
l'euro tout le monde n'est pas dans
l'euro chacun choisit ce vers quoi il
veut aller en dehors du socle des
valeurs fondamentales et en particulier
du respect de l'état de droit mais pour
le reste chacun avance à son rythme
l'avion le saint des thèmes voilà il ya
les lignes de fractures importantes
gerbage l espagnol en fait non c'est pas
le sujet les équipements de la rukoko
maintenance et des entraînements communs
c'est une capacité à se projeter par
exemple lorsqu'on a vu le retrait
américain de kaboul je pense que même
julie riendeau d'où les d'accord avec
moi nous ne voulons pas dépendre des
américains quand nous voulons rapatrier
nos ressortissants d'un pays en crise
nous avons vu que nous dépendions
exclusivement des états unis il faut
être capable d'avoir une force qui se
déploie dans un environnement très
exigeant et qui nous permet de faire un
pont aérien c'est de l'indépendance
stratégique ça devrait être voilà d'où à
votre oreille je viens odoul au fond il
faut qu'on soit plus fort à 25 pour être
indépendant souverain
vis-à-vis des jeunes sont l'indépendance
de peut être que nationales comme la
souveraineté est forcément arrivé à la
nation je vous expliquer pourquoi
vous voyez ce qui s'est passé et la
crise actuelle au sahel montre que c'est
la france qui dépend de la france et
c'est les français qui aujourd'hui
assurent la sécurité des français et
d'ailleurs des européens l'europe ne
nous aident pas il n'y a pas beaucoup de
soldats allemands qui sont au sahel il
faut bien le dire c'est des soldats
français qui versent leur sang et moi
j'ai pas envie que une armée française
est un commandant étrangers un
commandement étrangers qui décident
d'envoyer des fils de france se faire
tuer
alors sur le couple franco-allemand ja
je pense qu'il faut un moment donné
regarder la réalité en face et se
réveillait est très fâché en allemagne
ou encore les allemands ne nous pour
être dans un couple en fait il faut que
les deux parties cem et il faut regarder
dans la même direction les allemands ne
regarde pas dans notre direction que ce
soit sur la défense que ce soit sur
l'économie les allemands ne gagnent eux
assurent que leur intérêt à eux est
d'ailleurs quand ils ont repéré le
réarmement récent don quand ils ont
engagé le réarmement ils font pas appel
à l'industrie centre a16 ils font appel
à des avions f 16 américain deviendra
secondaire
mais on est obligé d'être en couple on
peut être sediba on peut être libre et
au célibat et non l'isolément vous savez
c'est avec un oiseau vous avez été
séduit d'affaires comme moi eh bien on
vous avez des amis vous avez des amis
vous n'êtes pas isolé vous savez vous
pouvez avoir des parents
tandis que d'être
libre je préfère être libre et pouvoir
décider puisque vous êtes endettés
auprès de la russie regarde aller
oui la question fait elle sera sur
l'allemagne pourquoi pas ce que vous
dites les allemands ne nous aime pas
c'est quand même s'exprimer en leur
place laissons les s'exprimer mais
qu'est ce que vous reprochez politiques
n'ont vu que j'étais bien comprendre qu
est ce que vous reprochez qu'est ce que
l'on reproché à l'allemagne aujourd'hui
en 2022 qu'est ce que vous lui reprochez
en gros qu'est-ce que là où est ce que
l'allemagne aujourd'hui aller au sein de
l'union européenne l'a rapidement une
réponse et vous mode je reproche plus au
gouvernement français
attendez attendez attendez appareil au
monde et que les que les allemands
assurent leur intérêt garanti ses
intérêts de l'allemagne je trouve ça
normal est ce que vous reprochez à
l'allemagne en quoi elle fait mal à la
france aujourd'hui parce qu' elle ne
garantit pas nos intérêts notamment
l'industrie militaire française acheter
des avions américains en quoi c'est
finalement favorisé comme on dit
l'europe de la défense en quoi c'est
favoriser le couple franco allemand on
voit bien que l'allemagne qui ne croient
pas la dissuasion nucléaire pourtant
qu'il veut avec les renforts de certains
de la macro nick qui veut notre ciel
vous partagez notre siège au conseil de
sécurité des nations unies n'est fait
qu'ils ne croient qu'à l'hôtel
pour conclure 6 assène nathalie
d'oiseaux à cette idée au fond d'eux
d'une allemagne qui ne regarderai que
ses intérêts
emmanuel macron a convaincu l'allemagne
à l'époque angela merkel de faire le
plan de relance de fer l'endettement en
commun aujourd'hui l'allemagne augmente
son budget de défense elle avait besoin
immédiatement d'avions de chasse qui
puisse porter des charges nucléaires
américaines parce qu'elle croit à la
dissuasion nucléaire contrairement à ce
que nous dit monsieur odoul les rafales
ne pouvait pas portant classement
aujourd'hui la france l'allemagne et
l'espagne qu'on construise le futur de
l'aviation européenne construisent le
char du futur et heureusement nous avons
aussi convaincu l'allemagne que la
défense européenne était une priorité on
s'arrête là merci infiniment c'était
très clair on voit bien les lignes de
fracture merci beaucoup richard et on va
continuer comme ça jusqu'au deuxième
tour à vous proposer des débats avec les
représentants des deux finalistes merci
merci à vous on va à présent accueillir
notre grand témoin pour continuer
d'ailleurs analysé cette campagne de
deuxième tour macron le pen l'affiché la
même qu'il ya cinq ans et en même temps
on a le sentiment que tout a changé
alors d'où vient cette impression que
les rôles se sont peut être inversé la
sérénité pour l'une l'offensive pour
l'autre on a plein de questions à poser
aux communicants raphaël lorca qui nous
invite dans son dernier livre à faire
tomber les masques hélène bonduelle
on vous invitera fait leur cas c'est que
l'extrême droite une nouvelle fois hissé
au second tour de l'élection
présidentielle est au coeur de votre
dernier ouvrage les nouveaux masques de
l'extrême droite avec un nouvel invité
dans le bal masqué de la politique eric
zemmour ton a changé parce que nous
sommes arrivés raphaël leur cas vous
êtes communiquant expert associé à la
fondation jean jaurès et doctorant en
philosophie du langage
ces masques que vous analysez dans votre
livre ne sont pas là pour dissimuler
mais pour donner à voir à marine le pen
le masque neutre à eric zemmour le
masques expressifs celui de la
radicalité m'avait été habitué à l'idée
selon laquelle la stratégie de l'extrême
droite pour gagner c'était la force
centripète ça des remparts de la marge
n'en revient vers le centre en
adoucissant la forme strategylab et
diabolisation ce qui est tout à fait
saisissant et ce qui effectivement
explique aussi l'incapacité de d'un bon
nombre d'observateurs pedica comprendre
cette stratégie-là d'eric zemmour c'est
une force centrifuge l'objectif n'est
pas de se radoucir l'objectif est de
radicaliser les gens le langage en dit
long sur la stratégie des politiques
comme cette parole décomplexée que vous
analysez chez eric zemmour et notamment
cette formule pour qualifier la peur de
l'invasion migratoire le grand
remplacement touche toute la france et
les nuisances de l'immigration touche
toute la france des mots qui seront même
repris par la candidate républicaine
valérie pécresse lors de son premier
meeting
c'est ce que vous appelez le déplacement
de la fenêtre d'ouverture
théorisée par le lobbyiste américain du
même nom elle ouvre le champ de
l'acceptable du dicible un politique un
propos devient que c'est pas le parti
allemand où il fait l'objet de débats ça
va partir mais on peut être pour ou
contre eric zemmour est un rôle
prédominant dans cette façon de
visibiliser et de donner du crédit à
cette thèse là avant d'être candidat
mais ce masque de la radicalité n'a pas
payé pour le candidat reconquête eric
zemmour diaboliser at il rendu marine le
pen plus sympathique plus inoffensive je
dis simplement que malgré tous les
efforts le vrai visage de l'extrême
droite revient alors le masque neutre de
marine le pen tiendra-t-il jusqu'au
second tour
bonsoir appel hors cac merci beaucoup
d'être avec nous vous êtes donc
communicants expert associé à la
fondation jean jaurès vous allez nous
dire au fond quelles sont ces nouveaux
masques de l'extrême droite votre essai
est publié aux éditions de l'aube il y a
à peine un an les français ne voulaient
pas de la fiche de 2017 macron le pen la
revoilà en 2022 mais est ce que c'est
vraiment la même affiche au fond votre
livre nous incite à penser le contraire
effectivement la grande erreur c'est de
penser que ce débat d'entre deux tours
est ce cet entre-deux-tours cette
affiche là soit se déroulera exactement
ce même terrain parce qu'entre temps
beaucoup de choses ont changé chez
emmanuel macron et surtout chez marine
le pen c'est marine effectivement elle a
compris qu'il fallait d'abord d'un point
de vue défensif venir gommer tous les
traits d'image qui lui collait à la peau
deux traits d'image très important
premièrement manque de crédibilité
incompétence manque de travail et donc
elle est revenue méthodiquement pendant
cinq ans pour dédé multiplié les signes
de crédibilité je veux pour preuve la
quinzaine de livres et thématiques
quelqu'un dont elle se réclame souvent
alors quand on rentre dans le détail
j'ai souvent en tête l'expression david
graiver sur des bullshit job il raconté
que lorsque des consultants de faire
semblant de travailler il fonde et
powerpoint là c'est un peu la même chose
c'est du bullshit politique c'est à
quelle serait faire rendre dans le
couvent à ce programme chine précis
s'est livré les personnes autour d'elle
qui se sont dit si l'expert tableau
extrêmement chien extrêmement sérieux
qui donne les atouts d'une sérieuse
quand on regarde dans le détail tout un
tas de journalistes ont fait le travail
le chiffrage est totalement fantaisiste
donc est un élément très important sur
la crédulité le débat ce qu'elle est
revenue là dessus c'était c'était un
crash industriel en direct au lieu de
laisser penser comme laissé entendre
d'ailleurs eric zemmour lui même et
toutes ses équipes c'est par manque de
travail et par manque de compétences
qu'à la foire il déballe il ya cinq ans
non a laissé entendre que c'était plutôt
un manque une mauvaise gestion de sa
fatigue et qu'elle arrive exténué avec
ce petit récit la migraine ophtalmique
donc c'est tout ça c'est très important
premier élément défensif correction ce
trait d'image manque de crédibilité ça
fonctionne quand on interroge les
françaises qu'à l'habitude d'être
présidente il ya cinq ans il ya 21 % en
france des français seulement qu il
estimé aujourd'hui sont deux fois plus
nombreux 39% c'est encore derrière
emmanuel macron qui de loin encore à 65%
mais quand on regarde derrière quand on
compare à tous les autres candidats elle
est nettement devant premiers éléments
manquent de crédibilité deux éléments
très importants et je vois encore ce
débat se dérouler dans l'entre-deux
tours et je m'en désole l'étiquette
d'extrême droite oui effectivement elle
le sait c'est une étiquette qui est
infamante où effectivement qui suscite
par réflexe un front républicain donc le
plus possible sa capacité à décoller
cette étiquette des larges instamment à
susciter le débat et ben c'est toute une
stratégie pas là c'est une stratégie que
vous expliquer très bien une stratégie
de neutralisation alors la
dédiabolisation ça ça fait des années
qu'elle a entreprise elle à la fois fait
le ménage dans son parti elle a dit des
choses aussi sur l'histoire
antisémite de la collaboration de la
question du détail de l'histoire fameux
cette fameuse formule combien grave de
son père mais ça c'est pas plus le plus
fort aujourd'hui parce qu'aujourd'hui on
a l'impression qu'elle a même
dépolitiser un certain nombre de ces
thèmes absolument elle a fait quelque
chose qu'elle ne faisait pas du tout
landais précédente campagne
présidentielle c'est qu'elle a exhumé et
qui exhibait un mas de la femme cabossé
et là je prends l'exemple du masque non
pas comme le mas qui dissimule faire
quelque chose qui serait faux non c'est
au contraire un masque sincérité non
mais c'est un masque d'ailleurs conçu
comme une construction artistique etc
tic qui souligne des traits véritable
mais quand survalorise volontairement
donc ça c'est la mère célibataire
qui élève ses enfants qui vit avec sa
colocataire sa meilleure copine voyez
comment on peut dérouler tout le récit
très facilement et quand on fait des
focus groups c'est très impressionnant
c'est que c'est ça qui revient en
premier c'est que j'entendais encore
hier sur le plateau de cyril hanouna
l'ancienne miss france qui disait c'est
la mère des français et donc tous ces
éléments-là de la girl next door très
rassurant très apaisante et c'est à ça
compte beaucoup un sale con tu mens
évidemment c'est impossible de ne pas
vous parler des chats parce que on se
rend compte que ils sont très politique
je sèche a expliqué nous ça c'est
l'animal inoffensif par excellence on la
voit partout et elle a beaucoup beaucoup
communiquer là dessus alors quand je dis
qu'il ya des choses qui perd cole dans
l'imaginaire c'est en fait partie quand
on interroge les gens focus groups c'est
quoi le premier mot qui vous vient à
l'esprit pour qualifier marine le pen
c'est pas le mot femme balmont extrême
droite c'est pas jean marie le pen c'est
le mot chat alors ça paris stupéfiants
mais il ya des raisons à cela c'est
qu'en fait le chat dans l'imaginaire
politique que ça dégage ça rentrent en
résonance avec deux choses premier
élément l'état de la société aujourd'hui
qui structurent et non papa l'a fait par
l'appelant par la colère par la fatigue
et se chasser l'animal du foyer de
l'intime de cette situation du cocon
dont a parlé que ces dames ans le
journaliste vincent coq berre est donc
effectivement ça dégage une imagerie
politique à des années lumières du
pachyderme qui était rhinocéros qu'elle
nous endort avec la 1re et c'est le
deuxième élément sa entend raison c'est
que sa stratégie politique qui n'est
plus la coalition des mécontentements et
des colères quand on a pu le faire en
2012 en 2017 qui ni stratégie populiste
on agrège y compris les fâcher pas facho
cette fois ci elle même ce qu'on
qualifie souvent de stratégie de
deuxième tour cirque ça consiste à dire
s'il ya un chemin de la victoire ça
consiste précisément à venir neutraliser
elle revient ce mot-là ce réflexe anti
extrêmement et c'est pour ça que ce
ronronnement du front républicain ça
entre en résonance avec le ronronnement
effectivement du chant neutraliser sa
demande une explication cette notion du
neutre vous en parlait déjà dans votre
premier essai dans la marque macron
c'était d'ailleurs le masque d'une autre
portée par emmanuel macron a changé au
fond de visage c'est elle qui le porte
ça veut dire quoi le nôtre voulant
emprunter à roland barthes exactement
c'est celle appel au calme le
dépassement du conflit c'est quoi
exactement pour l'être très précis le
neutre c'est on l'atteint séné août rc
ni l'un ni l'autre c'est toujours une
troisième voie et roland barthes nous
dit et je trouve ça extrêmement puissant
pour commandes à la fois la victoire de
macron 2007 et skate avec de fermes à
une bonne aujourd'hui c'est un
dépassement des tensions c'est un autre
qui esquivent les conflits qui les
disent ou qui fait un pas de côté pour
essayer de dépasser les antagonismes les
conflits les binarité emmanuel macron
ainsi de le faire entre la droite et la
gauche en gros son récit en 2007 c'est
quoi c'est de dire il est capable on est
capable de réformer le pays en dépassant
les clivages politiques ancestraux les
batailles qui n'ont plus le dec de la
bienveillance
effectif roland barthes 10 des figures
du nom de la première figure de notsé la
bienveillance et ce qui m'a mis la puce
à l'oreille c'est ce mot là lors des
campagnes régionales de 2021 elle
raconte cette campagne juste avant les
résultats décevants pour son parti elle
dit nous avons mené cette campagne avec
un esprit de joie d'optimisme et de
bienveillance là je me suis dit c'est
intéressant parce que s qu'elle ne
serait pas en train d'essayer de
récupérer ce flambeau du neutre qu'à mon
avis hein et le maquereau a abandonné au
cours du pouvoir je faisais l'hypothèse
dans le précédent livre qu'il avait
durci ce n'est dans une forme de
neutralisation dans un système de voir
beaucoup plus ferme et politiques d'un
point de vue médiatique et au fond il y
avait des orphelins d'une sur sa
capacité à dire par une société violente
dans la rue dans le travail dans la
politique les figures des dirigeants qui
sont capables d'esquiver le conflit le
dépasse et d'apaiser donc elle a une
forme d'agression a quand même envie en
captant cette figure d'une heure d'une
aidé par eric zemmour qui me fait le
pari de la violence de la brutalité et
la radio le politico émotionnel
divergentes entre les deux c'est à la
sortie de l'été où elle constate elle
regarde le début de campagne de zemmour
et elle dit et à l'époque on se moque
beaucoup la france n'a pas besoin ou de
donald trump français et pourquoi est ce
qu'elle dit ça parce qu'elle comprend
que la vague populiste sur lesquels elle
comptait lors des précédentes élections
présidentielles encore une fois
structuré par la colère par la haine et
de volonté de renverser le système elle
est finie potez que en sortie de
quinquennat crise il est jaune
confinement successifs imaginaire de
menaces on n'était pas encore mais ça a
été encore plus accentuée au ninas
nucléaire avec les conflits en ukraine
tout ça fait qu'elle fait une intuition
effectivement c'est il faut lui rendre
hommage stratégiquement c'est qu'elle
fait l'hypothèse que zemmour et sa
stratégie de la radicalité ça ira dans
le mur parce qu'au fond la france
n'atteint faire peur qui est
nerveusement la france à les fatiguer et
faut accompagner cette apathie
généralisée et elle n'a eu de cesse dans
une forme de stratégie du somnifère
devenir endormir d'accompagner mollement
l'apathie générale etc ce qui fait que l
a utilisé est mourant paratonnerre je
pense que c'est très important le
souligner c'est que on découvre
maintenant on doit faire dans
l'entre-deux-tours en quinze jours tout
le travail de déconstruction de son
programme qu'on aurait dû faire depuis
six mois et que les médicaments est
avancé masqué en stack que masquer par
exe moore qui par sa radicalité a
suscité beaucoup de critiques mais un
mot sur l'inversion des masques
justement dans dans cet entre-deux tours
elle est là ce masque au fond de la
sérénité d'une autre et on al impression
qu emmanuel macron au contraire attaques
parfois improvise au gré d'un bain de
foule change son programme est beaucoup
plus offensif qu'est ce que ça peut
donner lors du débat de mercredi
prochain le grand débat attendu par les
français d'entre deux tours je suis très
frappé linverse toutes les polarités
dont elle était victime en 2017 vous
avez parlé de cannes agressivité c'est
le premier deuxième élément très
important dans la rhétorique anti
extrême droite unités division en 2007
c'était emmanuel macron qui était le
candidat du rassemblement du front
républicain et puis l'extrême droite par
définition était celle qui allait
diviser la société française l inverse
lille où le président de l'unité qui
bannit les gilets jaunes qui emmerde et
les non vaccinés qui n'a eu de cesse
dans mes d'opposer les français les uns
aux autres je suis dit elle la candidate
de multinationales donc deuxième
aversion unités désignant est peut-être
la troisième ce programme effectivement
en 2017 qu'on était d'accord avec lui ou
pas il y avait la perception que c'était
emmanuel macron qui avaient un projet
clair qu'ils avaient un ensemble de
mesures cohérentes et marine le pen qui
a accosté paraissait comme démago avec
des mesures d'ailleurs dentelle ce
qu'elle l'abandonné dans l'entre-deux
tours avec le ralliement avec nicolas
dupont aignan là on se rend compte que
c'est le contraire ça qu'elle dit et
vous allez écouter même macron il des
rôles 150 mesures techniques pendant une
heure et demie dans de son meeting mais
quel cas parce que ça dessine et surtout
elle pointe du doigt avec cruauté les
reniements successives des menus macron
dans cette dans cet entre-deux-tours
donc il ya une forme d' inversion qui
alors un est inquiétant en soi parce que
ça prive d'un certain nombre de cartes
du président de la république pour
attaquer l'extrêmement dans ce débat et
je crois que ça met en valeur le fait
qu'on ne pourra pas
mener la bataille rhétorique qui est
celle du débat d'entre deux tours
mercredi prochain de la même manière en
2022 qu'en 2010 s'annonce différent tous
les cas merci infiniment raphaël hors
cac c'est passionnant elles avancent
masqués c'est bel et bien l'extrême
droite derrière le masque les nouveaux
masques de l'extrême droite c'est aux
éditions de l'aube propose de rester
avec moi parce qu'on va continuer d'une
certaine façon à passer au crible cet
entre deux tours avec nos chroniqueurs
ça s'appelle le scam et c'est maintenant
mais avant mais il y a les deux bras de
fatalité au grand remplacement et de la
mole vous propose le rose dalmore d'agir
pour le climat l'assimilation
la république c'est moi la prendre
orange ma chronique
travail aux travailleurs le système aux
exclus il ya un vrai problème de pouvoir
d'achat rendre à la france sa grandeur
la russie à cela pas de mystère c'est de
vol
ils sont en pleine forme même si la
semaine s'achève stéphane lacoste qui
vont fois isabelle lasserre d'un
excellent figaro rédactrice en chef des
pages internationales et brandon ouaret
qui va nous parler page est en train de
vie
du couple philippe macron qui sait que
c'est renouer au havre aujourd'hui on
commence avec le carnet de campagne
l'oeil de blacko ce soir a tiré par qui
par quoi matin j'ai ouvert les yeux en
sursaut mais ça arrive on fait un
cauchemar on ouvre grand les yeux et on
se dit mais il m'est arrivé un truc
affreux qu'est ce qui s'est passé et on
a du mal à souvenirs sous ses cauchemars
oui allez raconter nord merci je me
doutais qu'elle va me demander de
raconter bah oui cette nuit j'ai rêvé
mitterrand il était là devant moi il me
disait goguenard contre un peu avec
l'accent mi temps 10 dont black ops qui
le ps est mort vous n'en voulant parler
même pas de bottes creuseront chronique
là je me suis réveillé en sursaut j'ai
le coeur qui battait à 180 jeu mais le
ps est mort mon dieu on y lit mais
depuis je me suis souvenu jean n'a en
fait rien n'a filtré texte soit mort et
non me suis rendormi bon
on peut le dire qu'il est mort
aujourd'hui non je voyais que ça vous
fait de la peine de la famille du
patient quand adam berg courageux zone
et moi la main non mais donnez-moi la
mare je vais vous dire
le pronostic vital est engagé koné ces
matches là oui se croise et le maire
dont c'est exactement le maire de nancy
et lyon en 2001 bris là je pars à peu
près l'âge de macron donc il a été élu
maire unifiée alors que la ville était
n'avait pas une mare de gauche depuis 70
ans donc c'est un peu l'avenir du ps bah
vous savez ce qu'il a dit mathieu plein
d'avenir du ps regardez c'est le retour
de mon coach m'a marqué le parti
socialiste est mort ouais d'accord vos
cauchemars vous poursuivront le journal
c'est qu'il ya quand même un problème
alors bon bien sûr à l'antenne de radio
bleu on l'interrogé andy roddick no que
le ps est mort cette épreuve n'a pas
convaincu et louis à l'évidence le ps
aujourd'hui
d'épinés est maintenant terminée il n'a
pas dix morts ladite terminée voilà
c'est un footeux féminisme
ps d'or simplement il ne se réveillera
plus quoi simplement il fait beau
et d'anneaux était pour d'euthanasie
elle s était dans son programme regardez
ses marques et
bien d'une maladie la galère est ce
qu'il n'est pas temps de mettre tant de
médecins aux souffrances de la société
si on tire pas sur une ambulance vous
connaissez cette première sortie pour
finir dans la dignité jeudi il ya quand
même encore un ancrage local le ps il a
beaucoup de régions il a même cinq
régions sur 13 ça c'est pareil non mais
ça ça va rires vers 16 ça va rien dire
les gens peuvent très bien être morts et
continue à bouger
appelle les zombies je veux pas faire de
l'appropriation culturelle c'est un truc
des antilles enfin ça existe tout le
monde est au courant on franchement
regarde le pen ou encore ok mais son
acte de décès a été signé il ya quatre
ans le docteur valls il ya quatre ans à
signer l'acte de décès on écoute je
pense que le cycle de la
social-démocratie de ce qu'elle parti
socialiste ce cycle en europe comme en
france est terminée je pense que le
parti socialiste a terminé son rôle
historique qu'il faut reconstruire
quelque chose de totalement différent
parti socialiste des morts ah oui là il
n'y a pas de féminisme là ils la
voulaient peut-être un malin plaisir à
le dire oui alors lui qu'elle est partie
des partis chez mattel maintenant si
vous voulez la vie d'un deuxième
spécialiste c'est vrai quand on vous dit
que vous êtes mort vous préférez avoir
un deuxième avis médical pour pro
vérifier alors voici l'avis du docteur
cathelin tous avec demont discuter à la
lumière y compris du nouveau rapport de
force qui est celui que l'on voit la
sortie des urnes hier je veux dire
clairement on comprend que l'avenir de
ce pays à gauche ça n'est pas la social
démocratie c'est ce bloc populaire que
nous avons constitué bon rire bien sûr
y'a le spd en allemagne la social
démocratie n'a pas totalement mais qui
pourrait ressusciter ressuscité deux
parties se dit alors hier françois
hollande qui aimerait bien prendre
europe il est ce soir sur tf1 vous avez
la blague pas françois hollande ce soir
certains franchement bien ce qu'il
faudrait c'est un mâle alpha en fait
dans cette histoire et donc on ne parle
pas de françois hollande évidemment
parce que regarder mais ce qui s'est
passé au légiste présidentielle en la
beauté plus pour des personnalités
prendre un point au programme on a voté
pour macron on avait des pour mélenchon
la paix par le pen vous qui sont ces
gens là
femme ségolène royal mais oui moi je dit
ça évidemment parce que si on compte sur
anne hidalgo pour
excuser mon arrête de dire anne hidalgo
on arrête de dire transformer en
revanche ségolène royal oui
effectivement ll avait vraiment un
projet pour la gauche simplement
personnes l'écouté et quand elle l'a
expliqué c'était un peu trop tard la
dame qui donne par les s'appelle
ségolène royal fait 19 millions de voix
en 2007 anne hidalgo elle a fait 600
mille voix donc moi ça ne m'empêche pas
de dormir mais franchement pour le ps
c'est un vrai cauchemar alors qu'à la
fondation jean jaurès bah oui c'est le
pf que je suis je ris jaune à cette
chronique mais gégé bonnes espèces clés
des efforts en allemagne et voilà c'est
lui notre espoir il peut renaître
j'espère je crois oui pensez on verra on
verra si ça passe par un changement de
nom si ça passe par une régénération on
verra alors on continue à parler
politique avec avec brandon ce soir
déplacement de campagne au havre sur les
terres de son ancien premier ministre
emmanuel macron à retrouver et beau fils
mais les deux hommes se sont retrouvés
sous un beau soleil normand et bienvenue
au havre a tweeté l'ancien premier
ministre et vous allez voir l'accueil
était chaleureux
peut-être même un peu trop
est-ce qu'on a les images moi je vais
arriver je fais ben arfa n'ont même pas
de panique ça arrive est ce qu'elles
sont là moi je peux vous vous dire qu'il
ya une poignée de main oui justement que
vous accusez les images
qui bondit de sa voiture
demers y aurait six
bons c'est tout elles vont arriver dont
on voit emmanuel macron tout cas qui
bondit de sa voiture pour se jeter dans
les bras de son ex premier ministre
l'ong pauline mains tape sur l'épaule
sourire et à proximité et affection
c'est ça l'amitié et lorsqu'une
journaliste lui demande si la sortie
soleil pour emmanuel macron il répond
quoi edouard philippe
on écoute il fait toujours beau
vous avez vu un il prend un ton appuyé
saccadé ça me fait plaisir absolument il
est nerveux et déterminé on sent quand
même l'hypocrisie
c'est justement du havre il est plutôt
orageux entre entre philippe et makro
quand on connaît leurs relations
glaciales depuis plusieurs semaines si
on outrepasse en tout cas l'enjeu de ce
déplacement sur la forme ce n'est que de
la communication pure et dure les deux
jouent la carte décontracté mais ça
sonne faux alors quelle est la stratégie
dans cette campagne c'est une stratégie
qui rappelle nicolas sarkozy en 2002
quand il faisait campagne pour la
réélection de jacques chirac et en même
temps il se préparait pour la
présidentielle de 2007 c'est un peu ce
que ce qui est en train de faire edouard
philippe ils préparent la campagne et
pour faire réélire forcément emmanuel
macron et en même temps bas ils
s'échauffent avant de se tourner vers
l'horizon l'oeil sur les législatives et
le viseur sur la prochaine
présidentielle et souvenez vous quand
même de cette séquence assez étonnante
c'était le 2 avril dernier à la sortie
du grand meeting d emmanuel macron à la
défense arena on voit un edouard
philippe dans un café assis debout sur
debout sur une chaise et il fait un
discours il improvise un discours devant
ses principaux soutiens écoutez le
cétacé marquant le seul objectif que ce
que je vous demande d'avoir en tête dans
les trois semaines qui viennent c'est de
gagner l'élection présidentielle et
ensuite ensuite horizon prendra toute sa
part dans la majorité
[Applaudissements]
il va dire qu'à une ambiguïté il répète
calmement avec ce sourire espiègle très
révélateur après tout le nom de son
parti ses horizons et horizon proche
horizon lointain voyage légistatives
2022 ou présidence et 2027 alors on
expliqué nous un peu le dessous des
cartes ça fait un moment quand même qu
edouard philippe et joue sur un certain
ambiguïté mais l'ancien premier ministre
veut placer ses pions dans l'après
présidentielle
il vise un groupe suffisamment large à
l'assemblée pour poser au sein de la
majorité mais ça ne va pas être très
facile puisqu'il n'avait pas réussi déjà
à fusionner son parti horizon avec agir
en octobre dernier emmanuel macron avait
posé son veto et depuis le climat n'a
jamais été aussi tendues entre les deux
hommes et ça ne risque pas de s'arranger
puisque dimanche lors de son discours du
1er tour emmanuel macron a été très
clair sur ses nouvelles ambitions écoute
moi là il envoie un message très fort et
tacle encore une fois en même temps
edouard philippe il ne souhaite pas de
dispersion syllabes sort justement tout
le monde dans un grand mouvement quelle
serait la valeur ajoutée de leurs
philippe si oui il sachant qu'à droite
valérie pécresse et 4% premier tour sans
oublier l'embouteillage d'eric woerth
jean louis borloo et l'ombre de nicolas
sarkozy qui plane ou dit en gros party
ça marche pas on a eu
la priorité quand même c'est compte tenu
du score de jean luc mélenchon premier
tour notamment au havre c'est désormais
d'aller chasser à gauche donc l'horizon
d'edouard philippe qui semble s'éloigner
france inter il est interrogé par une
auditrice qui dit écoutez moi
franchement vous candidat j'aurai voté
pour vous mais jamais macro est plutôt
que de répondre classiquement ma bonne
dame n'y a pas une feuille de paie p tit
gars tenteront
voter magnet macro et ça me fait
vachement plaisir et vous me dites
j'étais très surpris par cette réponse
est il va falloir regarder ça de près
pour la campagne de philippe va falloir
le regarder pendant que maintenant on va
terminer avec vous et isabelle sujets
plus graves forcément l'ukraine joe
biden at il eu raison d'utiliser ce mot
de génocide pour évoquer les crimes
russe perpétrés dans le pays écoutez oui
et non à la fois myriam oui parce que la
définition du génocide ce sont des actes
commis dans l'intention de détruire un
groupe ou une partie d'un groupe
national ethnique racial ou religieux et
si on reprend les textes qui ont été
récemment publiés la fois sur les
réseaux sociaux et dans les médias
proches du kremlin par certains
idéologues proche de poutine et aussi
par l'ancien président dmitri medvedev
et bien l'intention elle pourrait bien
existé puisqu'il le puisque le programme
c'est de
déshumaniser le pays et que l'identité
ukrainienne est tout à fait nier parce
qu'elle est jugé artificiel est par
ailleurs depuis que les russes se sont
retirés de tous les villages au nord de
kiev quand puisqu'ils ont retirent leurs
troupes pour se masser près du dombass
on a découvert tout un tas d'atrocités
donc le premier c'était le massacre de
boudhha depuis il ya eu des centaines de
viols des exactions des centres de tri
enfin bref tout ce qui pourrait en tout
cas être saisi par la justice
internationale alors est ce qui est ce
qu'on parle est-ce qu'elle parlera de
crimes de guerre de crimes contre
l'humanité ou de génocide
le qualificatif de génocide avait été
retenue par le tribunal pénal
international pour l'ex yougoslavie en
1995 après le massacre après le massacre
de srebrenica
au cours duquel 8000 hommes et
adolescents avaient été tués par les
forces serbes de bosnie aujourd'hui on
ne peut pas savoir ce sera la réponse
sera après une longue enquête elle n'est
pas encore commencée la justice qui doit
dire si oui ou non ce génocide a été
commis emmanuel macron lui alors au
contraire a récusé le terme il a parlé
de crime de guerre mais il n'a pas voulu
aller jusque là pour le génocide et oui
parce qu'il manuel macro il n'a pas la
même liberté de parole que joe biden
d'abord ce qui prédit préside l'union
européenne et que sur ce sujet les pays
de l'est pays membres de l'ue eux sont
extrêmement divisée on a par exemple la
pologne et l'espagne qui ont
deux chefs de gouvernement qui ont aussi
parlé de génocide et en face on à
l'allemagne et l'italie qui ont des
positions beaucoup plus ambigu et puis
aussi emmanuel macron en coordination
avec ses partenaires européens a décidé
de maintenir un lien avec vladimir
poutine depuis le début de la guerre il
lui parle régulièrement alors pas depuis
la découverte des masses à gauche du
ring
l'allier la ligne n'est pas rompu allait
elle est interrompu et les mises entre
parenthèses mais il serait difficile
pour emmanuel macron de continuer à
parler avait dit mir poutine si le
traitaient comme joe biden de boucher ou
si ils l'accusaient de commettre un
génocide en même temps pour terminer
rapidement isabelle ça vaut des
critiques extrêmement sévère sur macro
en ukraine il ya ce mode macro n'est qui
a été inventé et la lumière hélène ski
volodymyr zelensky ne pardonne pas d'une
certaine façon près l'enfance et ouais
il considère que les propos de
d'emmanuel macron sons sont très
blessants alors il est normal que
volodymyr zelensky appuyé sur le
président qui préside l'union européenne
pour essayer de faire pression sur
l'europe mais on sent quand même chez
lui depuis quelques temps un certain
agacement vis-à-vis de la france et de
l'allemagne qui ce sont les deux pays
qui en 2008 avaient mis leur veto en
fait l'entraîneur des rations de le de
la géorgie et de l'ukraine au sein de
temps et 10 aujourd'hui si ces deux pays
n'avaient pas mis leur veto on serait
peut-être dans l'otan et cette guerre
n'aurait jamais déclaré il reproche
aussi aux français de ne pas livrer
assez d'armes et aux allemands d'avoir
été trop longtemps complaisant vis-à-vis
de l'avenir poutine en s'accrochant
notamment au gazoduc north stream de
brun et en refusant de faire l'embargo
sur le sur le gazole ou dell merci
beaucoup merci infiniment isabelle qui
suit ce dossier comme le lait sur le feu
mais resservi enfin si les ukrainiens
vont moins sympathique fait pas même pas
même pendant la campagne leur est la
défense de lestrem et on verra il reste
moins de dix jours maintenant merci
raphaël lorca les nouveaux masques de
l'extrême droite 7 aux éditions de
l'aube merci à vous à demain tout de
suite rendez-vous documentaire avec un
film sur le parti communiste français
parti du cinéma très belle soirée
[Musique]